Super Bowl media day is now given way to
opening night I mean it's super bowl 50
so you have to do it big and as always I
am joined by my partner in crime here at
the Super Bowl the one and only Michelle
Williams oh it's good to be back heaven
always great to have you here Michelle
and you know as this gets bigger each
and every year we have to make our tape
bigger so that's why Cassidy given is
here to experience her first-ever media
day what was it like for you it was
unlike anything I've ever been a part of
7 it was crazy pacity welcome to me
today well it was my very first Super
Bowl media day let me count down the
crazy there was a guy in a dress you
know we're from Germany and in Germany
we say we only get interviews here from
footballs if we look like you there were
puppets and I can't really understand
why there were puppets nor did they
speak English what does this have to do
with the Super Bowl and nos gustan mucho
Cepeda Wahlberg LBI maganos mucho
Cassidy got a taste of the craziness and
today her mom was emotional talking
about her daughter's debut last night as
an ET correspondent he's like they are
doing so much better than I could've
done I sweet his castle forgive me for
being along and so when those tweets
start coming in my natural she is up by
the way we you know just I was so
grateful when the Panthers Cam Newton
entered it was a spectacle and Peyton
Manning faced a wall of cameras Super
Bowl 50 air sunday on CBS Michelle and I
played a little round of NFL newlywed
game with their teammates with cut out
of their ladies most romantic thing
you've ever done proposed and the Grand
Canyon
where was your first kiss first kiss was
in Philadelphia after we ate at a
restaurant by the way back in the cab if
you could be a famous person who would
you be who did your wife say Kobe Kobe
Bryant does your fiancé prefer you in
spandex like your football uniform or
your birthday suits the birthday soon we
gave Xbox ones to the players with the
most correct answers and then this
happened what flower best describes your
wife in the morning a dead one she's not
she's not very she's not a very morning
person that is what we call just another
super wild Super Bowl media day a
leprechaun getting down on one knee was
most definitely the craziest thing that
has ever happened to me he didn't
propose Diddy I don't know I didn't
either that's what I was worried I just
don't want to get that call from your
mom like my daughter married a
leprechaun we shall help great were the
guys talking about their watch local
amazing love is a wonderful thing but
it's time to get back to some football
and you know what it's time to get back
to Hollywood let's send it back to the
studio